[Musique]
l'actualité du continent africain s'est
tout de suite sur france 24 à vis de
vous retrouver pour votre journal de
l'afrique la junte tchadienne s'allie à
une quarantaine de groupes rebelles un
accord qui pose les prémices du dialogue
national prévu le 20 août bémol
plusieurs factions n'ont pas signé j -
avant les élections au kenya scrutin à
locales législatives et présidentielle
le pays fait preuve de stabilité dans la
région ses voisins sont attentifs à
l'issue de ce vote nous serons à nairobi
nous irons également au gabon les forêts
de mangroves sont menacés sont menacés
et avec elle la pêche de crabes et de
couteaux de mer
la raison des projets immobiliers qui
arrivent par vagues
les négociations de ces cinq derniers
mois auront donc fini par payer un
accord a été conclu entre plus de 40
groupes rebelles et la junte tchadienne
celle dirigée par le fils du président
deby tué en avril 2021 celle aux
manettes depuis le texte doit aider à un
retour du pouvoir civil laurent
d'erstein
après cinq mois de négociations
acharnées le tchad pourrait enfin sortir
de l'impasse signé lundi par une
quarantaine de groupes rebelles l'accord
de doha devrait enfin ouvrir la voie au
dialogue national inclusif promis par
les autorités de transition
[Musique]
ce qui est important c'est que nous
sommes arrivés à la fin de ce long
processus de négociations
et je pense que cet accord nous mènera à
une paix durable
l'accord prévoit un cessez le feu
général et engage le gouvernement
tchadien à assurer la sécurité des
groupes signataires en vue de leur
participation au dialogue national le 20
août prochain un dialogue censé aboutir
à la tenue d'élections générales en
octobre et un retour au pouvoir civil
c'était en tout cas la promesse faite
par mahamat idriss deby itno lors de sa
prise de pouvoir en avril 2021 et si
l'accord de doha n'est pas une fin en
soi il représente une première avancée
face à une situation au point mort
depuis plusieurs mois nous accorde ne
suffisent pas
key signifie cinq mois ci permettent des
terres les armes dans un pays où l on
avec fracas et pendant longtemps parlé
reste un problème de taille pour les
autorités tchadiennes certains des
principaux groupes rebelles dont le très
actif et facettés ont refusé de signer
l'accord estimant qu'il ne prenait pas
en compte leurs revendications
effectivement à cet accord s'il est une
avancée significative il souffre de
l'absence de deux principaux groupes
rebelles l'un d'eux est à l'origine de
l'attaqué qui a tué l'ancien président
idriss déby mamadou hadji mbaye et
l'envoyé spécial de france 24 à doha le
qatar sous l'égide duquel s'est négocié
le texte
sur cinq ans des mouvements rebelles
présents à doha 43 soit la majorité ont
signé un accord de paix l accord qui
ouvre la voie pour un processus de paix
au tchad le gouvernement s'est dit
satisfait écoutons le porte parole
demain
nous sommes déterminés à faire le
dialogue là sera la crise et qui restent
l'épiné dorsale de la reconstruction
d'un type nouveau et nous nous
réjouissons que 43 mouvement sur la
cinquantaine et si gaie et c'est pour
nous une très très grande réussite nous
nous en félicitons
plus d'une dizaine de groupes
qui va permettre
inclusive qui va s'ouvrir le 20 août un
jeune
la raison avancée est la non prise en
compte de leurs revendications
parmi les groupes qui ont rejeté
l'accord se trouve le fact
effectivement nous n'avons pas signé
l'accord et cela pour deux raisons le
refi de la mise en place des nouvelles
colonies nous avons demandé qualité au
niveau des délégués du déni la
libération à compter de la signature de
l'accord de nos prisonniers de la
modification de la charte entre potes
par exemple point de couper dans
l'immédiat c'était
la raison pour laquelle nous avons passé
l'accord de source officielle
alassane ouattara joue la carte de
l'apaisement le président ivoirien
grassi laurent gbagbo l'ancien chef
d'état son prédécesseur son rival fait
l'objet d'une condamnation à 20 ans de
prison pour braquage il a été
définitivement acquitté l'an dernier par
à la cpi de crimes contre l'humanité
kevin batista
la grâce d'un président à son
prédécesseur
alassane ouattara offre son pardon
présidentiel à laurent
dans le souci de renforcer la cohésion
sociale j'ai signé un décret accordant
la grâce présidentielle à monsieur
laurent gbagbo j'ai également demandé
qu'il soit procédé au dégel de ses
comptes et au paiement de ces arriérés
de rente viagère le président ivoirien
accorde aussi la libération
conditionnelle à deux militaires proches
de l'ancien dirigeant laurent gbagbo a
quitté l'an dernier par la cour pénale
internationale de crimes de guerre et
est retourné dans son pays l'an dernier
le refus de ce dernier de reconnaître sa
défaite en 2010 face à alassane ouattara
avait entraîné une guerre civile faisant
3000 morts libre de ses mouvements il
restait pourtant sous le coup d'une
condamnation à 20 ans de prison pour la
justice ivoirienne il était responsable
de l'ouverture des coffres de la banque
centrale des états d'afrique de l'ouest
en plein conflit
la grâce de laurent gbagbo intervient
alors que le pays doit retourner aux
urnes l'an prochain pour des élections
locales et en 2025 pour la
présidentielle
les efforts de réconciliation nationale
les rencontres entre anciens ennemis
n'ont pas mis fin aux oppositions les
anciens présidents laurent gbagbo et
henri konan-bédié se disaient opposés en
2020 à une nouvelle candidature
d'alassane ouattara qu'ils estimaient
inconstitutionnelle
dans l'actualité du continent également
cette attaque dans le nord du mali
dimanche attersee dans la zone des trois
frontières la cible un camp militaire
bilan provisoire onze morts dont deux
civils et quatre soldats des djihadistes
sont pointés du doigt pas de
revendications non plus rance au mali
mais les al shebab sont dans le viseur
après ces tirs de mortier dimanche aux
abords du palais présidentiel à
mogadiscio le parlement venait
d'entériner la composition du
gouvernement au sein de l'équipe un
ancien responsable du groupe islamiste
puis 125 ans que le nigeria attendait
cela 72 oeuvres d'art vont lui être
restitués par le musée hormis nan de
londres les artefacts volé au 19e siècle
lors d'une incursion militaire
britannique à bénin city parmi eux 12
bronze du bénin
dans quelques heures plus de 22 millions
de kenyans ont rendez vous avec les
urnes il s'agira notamment d'élire le
cinquième président du pays de tourner
la page aussi douroux kenyatta lui qui a
tenu les rênes pendant dix ans lui qui a
joué le médiateur dans plusieurs crises
régionales notre correspondant bastien
renou nous explique en quoi cette
élection est scrutée de près par les
voisins ils se trouvent au centre
national où seront annoncés les
résultats
cette élection revêt une importance
toute particulière pour l'afrique de
l'est pour plusieurs raisons tout
d'abord la question de la démocratie le
kenya est entouré par des pays en guerre
comme la somalie l'ethiopie le soudan du
sud où d'autres qui sont plus
autoritaires comme l'ouganda et la
tanzanie le kenya fait donc figure
d'exemple dans la région des exemples de
démocratie et de liberté il est
important pourrait inspirer les autres
pays de la région que cela reste le cas
ensuite il ya la question des violences
en 2007 il y avait eu plus de 1100 morts
et près de 600 mille déplacés en 2017 il
y avait de nouveau eu des troubles post
électoraux il est important pour la
stabilité de la région que le pays reste
en paix et ce à plusieurs titres tout
d'abord pour le kenya est une plateforme
du commerce il ya de très nombreux biens
d'importation et d'exportation qui
transitent par le kenya à destination de
la région il ya aussi la question des
négociations dans les processus de paix
entamé par le kenya que ce soit au
soudan du sud en ethiopie ou encore en
république démocratique du congo pour
que ces négociations puissent poursuivre
il est important que le pays reste
stable et enfin il ya la question de la
communauté est africaine si aucun des
candidats n'a annoncé de programme
particulier on sait que tous ont des
relations particulières avec certains
leaders de le ac à savoir william ruto
qui est plutôt proche de yoweri musevini
le président ougandais ou à raila odinga
plutôt proche du félix tshisekedi le
président de la république démocratique
du congo donc il ya de fortes chances et
bien que l'élection de l'un ou l'autre
des candidats aura une influence sur la
politique est africaine au cours des
prochaines années
après le russe sergueï lavrov le
français emmanuel macron l'américain
anthony blinken le secrétaire d'état est
en visite sur le continent africain le
but est double effacer les traces
laissées par l'administration trump et
contrecarrer l'influencé du kremlin pour
sa première étape il a choisi l'afrique
du sud un partenariat vital selon le
chef de la diplomatie
ce que dit l'afrique du sud ce qu'elle
ferait à de fortes conséquences
mondiales
ce qui fait de ce dialogue stratégique
un forum vital
marquant un engagement sérieux de nos
deux gouvernements à cette relation
bilatérale
et au travail que nous faisons ensemble
non seulement entre nous mais aussi
régionalement imaginaire
les etats unis sont l'un de nos
partenaires les plus importants
j'apprécie l'engagement que vous avez
montré pour étendre nos relations
bilatérales
les liens que nous deux paysans forgée
lors de leur lutte pour la démocratie et
la justice sociale sont durables et ont
créé une base solide pour la coopération
de nos peuples dans le registre de
l'éducation du tourisme et des échanges
culturels
et après l'afrique du sud 1 anthony
blinken se rendra mardi en république
démocratique du congo et le lendemain
mercredi donc au rwanda - 70 ha ces
trois dernières années les mangroves du
nord du gabon perdre du terrain en cause
la construction de nouveaux logements et
d'hôtels conséquence la mise en danger
de l'économie locale basée
essentiellement sur la pêche reportage
10 miles et obiang landry kouassi où il
ferait dablé et annaba kita à une
vingtaine de kilomètres au nord de
libreville le petit village du cap
estérias au milieu des mangroves yade et
son frère recueille chez mattel à des
pièges à crabes poser la veille est
vraiment très bon ici les habitants
vivent essentiellement de la pêche
artisanale une activité aujourd'hui en
péril en cause la pression immobilière
qui détruit l'écosystème de reproduction
des crustacés conséquence les crabes ont
quasi disparu avant même d es la maison
je pouvoir voir les cram tu mettais 15
caisses en moins d'une heure des teintes
et 15 ans qu'elles sont attrapés vont
aujourd'hui quand vous voyez tout est
doublé même si on laisse vainqueur cela
n'allait pas attire la journée d'aller
aider n'y aurait que les crapules pas
parce qu il au soleil tape les caisses
la plus la mangrove premiers faux
face à la disparition annoncée de la
mangrove les bénévoles des ong comme le
prix même de vastes campagnes de
reboisement ce jour là ils sont sur ce
site de la rive est de l'estuaire sous
les palétuviers ils recherchent des
semences qu'ils vont replanter pour
faire repousser la mangrove et sauver
leur crustacés pourquoi on reboise est
premièrement c'est pour limiter
l'urbanisation anarchique
c'est pour limiter les spéculations
foncières
qui s'étend sur plusieurs kilomètres ici
sur un plat économique mais aussi sur un
plan environnemental
c'est pour pouvoir
permettre à ces espèces qui dépendent de
cette mangrove ne pouvoir se reproduire
face à la disparition annoncée de ce
riche écosystème les autorités
gabonaises renforce les mesures pour
contraindre les promoteurs immobiliers à
réaliser des études d'impact
environnemental avant de construire
auprès des mangroves
on a aujourd'hui une gamme qui a été
mise en place ici et avec l'appui des
ong
ça permet aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens
bêtes des donneurs dallaire et on
continue de sensibiliser aussi un
certain nombre de mesures par rapport à
certaines personnes qui récidive ou
qu'ils
n'obéissent pas aux injonctions qui leur
sont faites malgré ces dispositions
légales le littoral gabonais continue de
perdre sa mangrove alors même que le
code de l'environnement et
particulièrement son article 64 interdit
la construction de bâtiments sur des
sites naturels sensibles aux proches des
rivages
merci de votre fidélité au journal de
l'afrique l'actualité du continent s'est
aussi retrouvée sur france 24 points
comme et sur nos réseaux sociaux le
reste de l'actu internationale c'est
dans quelques minutes reste avec nous
sur france 24
[Musique]